il est grand il est beau et surtout il
est arrivé à tour alors non on ne parle
pas de vous Lucas on va parler du sapin
de Noël bien sû vous montriez du douir
en plus bravo j'ai eu espoir que mais
non mon beau sapin roi de jeanjo ce
sapin Norman de 15 m de haut dont d'un
couple de bertenis a été coupé ce matin
et il est arrivé sur la place Jean jores
où il sera décoré et trônera jusqu'au
fêtes de fin d'année Clémence Dosque a
suivi son périple jusqu'à la capitale
tourangel beaucoup d'animations ce matin
dans le jardin de la F Peron leur
connifère de 15 m de haut et sur le
départ c'est le futur saard de Noël de
la ville de tour un don plein de
symbolique pour
Christian mon beau-père travaillait à la
ville de tour et à l'époque c'était il
était charpentier couvreur et à l'époque
c'était eux qui qui mettaient les
décorations au sapin de Noël donc bah
malheureusement il est plus là ça il ait
certainement fait plaisir de voir ça
hein c'est ils avaient pas du tout le
même matériel hein c'était
ouéchelle jeai jamais vu faire mais
c'était autre chose l'opération est
délicate après tronçonnage le sapin est
soulevé à l'aide d'une grue il se
retrouve en train de flotter au beau
milieu du paysage pendant de longues
minutes une fois dans les air les
techniciens taillent son Tron selon un
gabarit il permettra d'enfoncer le sapin
plus facilement dans son socle devant la
mairie comm dit ma femme c'est il va
finir en beauté avec les guirlandes et
puis et puis les boules quoi et ça va
faire plaisir à beaucoup de gamins qui
vont voir le
sapin devant la ville de tour et voilà
c'est c'est sa fin de vie glorieuse si
on peut
dire le vent complique les opération il
faudra près de 30 minutes pour coucher
l'arbre sur le camion et pouvoir partir
faire la douzaine de kilomètres pour
rejoindre
tour accueilli non pas par la neige mais
sous la pluie le sapin vient de prendre
ses quartiers place jeanerè reste à
langirlandais et à l'illuminé avant de
lancer les festivités de fin
[Musique]
d'année